[Music]
[Music]
welcome to wisdom collide where we sift
through philosophy to find practical
advice that you can use in your everyday
life hi I'm Dan Hayes I'm joined by my
co-host dr. Greg Sadler today we're
talking about circles of connection and
care which may sound like kind of a
abstract or abstruse topic but it's
something I think a lot of people can
easily relate to what would you agree
about that yeah it's not a hard concept
to understand it's you know in a
plethora of different philosophical
traditions so there's a good chance that
you've experienced at some point
sometime in your life yeah and you know
what else is kind of cool about this is
it's a way of thinking about things that
you could actually visualize so if you
imagine to yourself a set of concentric
circles I mean you could put whatever
you want could be like the ski ball at
the chuck-e-cheese the thing that we
drop those balls into though all those
are concentric circles or it could be
anything else that you like that has
some small circle in the beginning or in
the middle right and then the solar
system yeah that works or a target right
all of these are are good visual
analogies to it so what's what's the
basic idea here in talking about these
circles so like the basic thing is that
we we grow up and we already have a
natural affinity for you know ourselves
and our parents and you know sometimes
our siblings that changes a lot I'm man
you're right on but you know for most of
us we have this very deep ingrained care
that we have for those people that are
closest to us and then we have certain
levels of lesser care but you still
appropriate or like take into
consideration the how your actions are
going to reflect upon other groups that
you're a part of so for example your
greater family maybe your neighborhood
your city your state country or on
you'll potentially even the world or the
universe yeah and sometimes you
you might say purely imaginary for a
person I've known some people at least
in the Chicagoland area who have said
that they've never actually gone outside
of the Chicago suburbs which was a
little mind blowing for me to find out
that that was the case but they swore
that that was the situation's so their
their connection to say Americans as a
whole I mean it they could see it on TV
or on the internet but it would have to
be kind of imaginary and I think when it
comes to like thinking about the world
as such that's there's no way we can
experience the world as a totality so we
we might know people in foreign
countries far away from us I you know I
routinely correspond with people
literally on the other side of the world
through through zoom as clients but we
you know we can't visualize that circle
except in our our imagination and you
know so these these circles we learn
about them you might say developmentally
right we start out as kids we know our
family unit maybe we see kids on the
playground we get introduced to school
and then we take social studies classes
and they teach us about other places and
hopefully we get some geography although
I don't really know how effective the
geography teaching is today going by
what my students seem to know about
where things are and my kids do I have
to admit as well but so when when we
learn these you could call them you know
circles or we can think of them as in
other ways as well what's what's the
really key takeaway from this you
mentioned affinity or affection or maybe
I missed the term we've talked here
variation oh right right yeah and then
we can talk about care and concern are
we are we the kind of creatures that
naturally only care about people who are
close to us close to us in in proximity
I'd say whoever we consider an in-group
and ah yeah yeah and so that can you
know change depending on like if your
religion
if you are part of a religion then
you're usually the people that ascribe
to at least your denomination whatever
happens to might be i'm usually consider
those people you're in groups you know
hey if you're a Packer fan you've got an
in-group that's an interesting one
because have you have you ever looked at
those maps that they did using Facebook
of counties and people's fan affiliation
you know it was very predictable like if
you're in the Chicagoland area Bears
fans right if you're out in Philly well
Eagles fans pretty much all of New
England is is Pats fan favorites yeah
but there's little like sprinklings all
over the place and there were there were
two teams that had a lot of counties in
weird places that were the majori
that not necessarily the majority but
the largest number of people in that
County belong to that fandom and it was
the Packers and can you guess who the
other one was Cowboys no although that
would make perfect sense like 20 years
ago
the Oilers really Oh weirdly enough you
know yeah but it you know that you're
onto something there because I've
experienced this you know when I was
living out in New York you could find
places that were Packers bars just about
anywhere my wife went to the one in New
York City called kettle of fish
where it's literally a basement bar and
Here Come stairs there they're serving
you know summer sausage and various
Wisconsin beers and lots of cheese and
she said that when you go in people are
talking in there you know fairly
hoity-toity New York accents but they're
all transplants and within 20 minutes
they're talking like us only maybe even
a little bit more Wisconsin II and we
went to we went to a Packers bar in
Boston and it was quite interesting it
was it was pretty packed you know
everyone was was there in Packers gear
and we were watching it and so we had
some sort of commonality look let's
bring this back to philosophy rather
than was talking about sports what's
going on there you you are share
in some sort of common experience and
you have you have some views and some
some commitments that you you also share
in common and then you can look at the
other person and even though you don't
know them from Adam you might buy them
uh a beer or you know give them five
when something good happens or you know
and look at them as if they they matter
as if they they are somebody who you
care about this is I think it's been
recalled other things from other people
but I like the way that you have all no
Harare refers to this concept as an
inter subjective reality and so yeah
yeah a thing that affects reality just
as much as an objective thing does even
though it only exists because we
subjectively all agree upon it so
another example is money has value only
because we agree upon it corporations or
only entities because we agree that they
are there's no body of a company unless
you consider the body the Charter but
you could rip the Charter and that still
would you know be able to maintain and
hold property yeah I like that idea and
it even works when there's opposition
like you can be from an area and be you
know like when you're say 18 19 20 and
you're like this place is terrible I
can't wait to get the hell out of here
and get to some cool place right but
you're still from that place you're
still marked as belonging to that that
inter subjective community and then you
know 20 years later you could be like
man it was so great back there I think
I'll move back there and one that I
found was really on encouraging was I I
used to ride a motorcycle a lot more and
and to you especially if you ride a
cruiser and you grow down the road and
you there's a thing called the high sign
that you flashed you every other biker
that you go down it's kind of like hey
I'm in the group you're the group you're
the group dressing I don't really know
much about that so does that work is it
something that's like universally
acknowledged it is
at least in the United States on and of
the subset of motorcyclists that you're
touring or have cruisers Singer
harley-davidson type you know black and
chrome type thing and the high sign is
like this and you hold it I guess on the
left side Oh calm down by your thigh on
and that's just like the you know I'm
sorry that I hadn't doing it wrong it's
this well they can nobody can see it and
on the radio anyway so whatever for
those people that might actually see
this video recording on and but yeah
it's it's a sign of solidarity it's you
know and then if you're like out I went
out to Sturgis one year and and enjoyed
that atmosphere and it pulled into a you
know campground and it was totally
filled up and just kind of like around
just like spotted someone that kind of
looked like he had you know a bike kinda
near me and I went over to him and said
like similar to mine and and say hey
like it's all filled up do you might
have thrown my tent up here I'll be out
right quick in the morning it's like
yeah whatever no problems like whatever
that's that was great and it was like
they had no reason to care about and he
besides the fact that we had both shared
in this particular you know semi
dangerous hobby yeah and to use some
other terms that were gonna employ to
discuss this as we look at some classic
just classic interpretations of this he
exerted benevolence towards here right
there's no need for him he doesn't know
you again like like I said for me Adam
and there's no like laws or rules that
say oh you have to welcome the person
who's got a motorcycle and wants to camp
next to you he he did something nice for
you he treated you as somebody who was
worth having a connection to right yeah
Wow so let's talk about one of the early
treatments of this and I picked out
Cicero the great Roman
orator and and lawyer as well and
statesman but also a philosopher and in
his book on duties which he wrote to his
son to try to give his son some idea
about how he should how he should think
about behavior and then how he ought to
regulate his behavior he talks about
justice and for the Stoics whose sister
was drawing on justice didn't just
include following the rules and keeping
her commitments and fulfilling duties
and giving everybody what they ought to
have it goes further than that it
includes benevolence you ought to try to
exhibit kindness to people when you can
and Cicero doesn't say you need to be
kind to everybody as a matter of fact
he's got some some you know strictures
about that don't be so kind that you
wind up being destitute but he does talk
about this this metaphor of circles and
he says that the closest circle is the
one that we know the the most our
friends our family those who are very
close to us and then we have those who
live in the same neighborhood so like
you and I both being fellow Milwaukee
ins I guess you could say would would be
within that circle right and then I'll
walk with you on that one
sure yeah yeah I mean we are both in in
the it's it's a bit of a bigger town I
think than Cicero may have had in mind
yeah so some people you have to talk
about neighborhoods then instead yeah
you're in River West I'm down here in
West town so then maybe we have a larger
one which then is the greater community
and at a certain point Cicero talks
about the what he calls the political
community or in his view of the Roman at
that time Roman Republic is soon to
become an empire within his lifetime as
Caesar manages to take over Cicero being
on the wrong side of everything and
while that happens and so Cicero also
then extends it out to the world and he
says we can think about Humanity is one
gigantic circle now Cicero's treatment
prioritizes the the nation or the
political community over the world and
he says that's actually the most
important one he also thinks that the
friends-and-family one is really
important so you know neighbors that you
know you should be good to them you
should connect with them in some way but
in a certain respect it's more important
to see them as fellow citizens than than
anything else and it seems to get at
this kind of idea of either you know the
the clash between loyalty and I guess
morality you know like a more absolute
sense yeah that's like is morality just
dependent upon those people that are
closest to us and can we you know say oh
well they're far away and thus morality
doesn't extend to them how I asked about
them I mean Cicero's kind of a stickler
for that he he even thinks that we owe
enemies in war time certain duties and
you know I guess in a way to be at war
with somebody is to push them out of the
circle to say I'm not going to treat you
with the same sort of care as I would
other people as a matter of fact if I
get a chance I'm gonna kill you or Mamie
or whatever else shun you in some way so
I think that at least with Cicero
himself there's a recognition of the
humanity even of the enemy but it's a
pretty limited recognition he's still
gonna try to kill them you know if you
take him prisoner you can't do anything
whatsoever you like to him as opposed to
other ancient treatments of prisoners
but and he also thinks he shouldn't lie
to your enemies which is a kind of a
weird thing we might explore in some
other discussion who was the the Roman
general who returned to Carthage after
he was captured oh yeah yeah I don't
remember because he'd given his word
right you're right every when I was a
youth yeah and everyone
like what are you doing this is this is
insane
yeah yeah well someone's got standards
apparently but you know there's
something behind that there's the the
recognition that and this gets to the
heart of it this recognition that these
these wider circles include other people
who we we ought to be willing to extend
the same sort of kindnesses the same
sort of respect the same sort of duties
as we would to those who we we know that
we should because we're closer to them
and and you know you brought up this
term loyalty as being something that
could be in conflict and and and I think
that that's quite true we often do
experience this sense that well we ought
to be treating other people better than
we we do or paying attention to them or
taking them into account but we feel a
greater loyalty to those who are close
to us we feel a greater affinity there's
almost like a natural basis for for that
I think the ancients thought so this is
a great jumping-off point into how do we
get beyond that and the Stoics had quite
a few things to say about that
right yeah so this is one of their
topics of ideas called okey osis which I
believe translates from the Greek to
appropriation and the idea is that
you're trying to appropriate into your
concern those concerns of others and so
we're taking now the circles that we
talked about in Cicero on and here
oakley's stoic philosopher is taking
these concentric circles and say we
should on constrict or contract these
circles into the idea that you should be
thinking about even the most far-flung
of the you know rational creatures and
so I love that they use this idea of
rational creatures instead of humans
because that you know it allows us to
have a greater like quantity of people
like if there are you know other
intelligent species in the universe that
we can include them as well as you know
some of
more intelligent nonhumanoid Terrence
I'm you know say badger I was wondering
if you're gonna go there that's yeah
that's an interesting thought some of
the height what we often call the higher
animals right right so octopi your
dolphins your elephants yeah yeah and
it's hard to figure out where we should
draw the line for that I mean should
pigs go in there they're pretty smart
right you know is there a consideration
because they're really tasty well that's
probably not that does not hold water
yeah I mean there's that old joke I
forget which comedian brought that up
where he was saying the reason this is a
terrible idea of course the reason why
we eat tuna and we don't eat dolphins is
because the dolphins are cute and Mikey
means more than just like looking cute
they do all these cool things and tuna
I've ever looked at them they're not
they're not very appealing so okay to
eat them there might be something to
that but then you know pick any animal
there's somebody who's found a way to
eat it and eat just about every single
part of the thing but in any case yeah I
like that idea of extending the the
notion of rationality
maybe elephants are to some degree
rational maybe octopi it's kind of a
hard sell but they're pretty they're
pretty adaptive they do a lot of problem
solving they they seem to have some sort
of conception of self so I don't know
maybe they are rational but so now let's
talk about another thing with us you
mentioned there's this notion of
contracting the circles and this is this
is a really interesting way to put it
because I think the natural tendency for
many of us would be to we start with our
first circle that of our parents
children siblings friends and then we we
would say oh we should expand that
outwards like we all become one big
happy family
like they always tell us at work usually
to get more work out of us oh you're not
you're not employees your family exactly
yeah and family means you can like you
know work them however you like and not
give them you know proper conditions we
could have a whole thing about that but
so normally we think about like
extending things outward I should I
should extend the same desire for the
good of the other I should extend the
same consideration I should extend the
same respect that I do I have here in
this small circle out to bigger circles
so why do you think here eclis says no
take the big circles and bring them
inside instead of saying like let's flow
this this outward do you think it's a
more effective way of thinking about it
bringing people close into you yeah just
think about like how you bring people
into those closer circles you know your
friends and you you spend time with them
you bring them closer to you and so I
feel like there is a a physical
connection of how we create close
relationships is to bring them closer to
us physically except for in these times
and yeah like six feet away yeah it's
close enough yeah and and so you know
the the metaphor works together easier
if we're thinking about you know
bringing people closer together even if
though they're not physically connected
together and now Herakles talks about
like visualizing this right this is this
is a stoic practice it's not just an
idea it's something that people would
would try to do on a daily basis or
perhaps in occasions of stress when
they're tempted to think about everybody
else as being a bunch of jerks that they
shouldn't care about right right yeah so
you you'd sit and meditate on this you
know maybe a morning or the evening
depending and and just like you know
meditate on the thought of like who
should I be thinking about in the things
that I do my actions have consequences
and
I need to be mindful of what those
consequences actually do to other people
yeah at regard I guess
regardless of who they are yeah and it
could lead us to thinking about not just
negatively you know how we can affect
them but what we might do for them as
well what we need to send to them or
keep in mind who do you want to talk
about next you we've got quite a few
other yeah I think we can definitely
touch ah I know you can either stay in
the Western tradition or you can go east
let's go east okay so let's go Buddhism
and Metta meditation uses a very similar
practice and it's you know Metta
translates as benevolence or
loving-kindness and as a similar idea of
trying to extend the I guess the
emotional feeling of loving-kindness or
benevolence to people that we might not
as easily interact within that same
mindsets and so if you can extend this
feeling then it allows us easier to make
decisions on them if they're on in that
like circle that you consider that you
can at least feel for yeah and you know
that's really interesting if you think
about people often bring up similarities
between stoicism and and Buddhism and we
do have this similarity of practices
between Reiki OSIS and Metta meditation
but I think there's a couple other
similarities as well I think that a lot
of people are surprised when they find
out that stoicism thinks that you know
compassion and affection for others and
you know reaching out to them would be a
good thing because they've you stoicism
as being primarily about like protecting
the self and not having emotional
attachments and I think there's a
similar thing with Buddhism too there's
there's sort of like a simplified way of
looking at Buddhism that's that
off-base that views it as well just
avoid attachments to anything alright
the whole goal is to to slip out of that
and yet the you know the largest group
of Buddhists Amaya Hana Buddhists are
the various schools associated with them
think that that this is quite important
and even some Vajrayana Buddhist
incorporate this as well so there's
there's a similar we could call it
misconception of Buddhism and stoicism
coming in from from the outside and
maybe from you know sketches of them
that that were not entirely well
grounded right
yes within stoic circles there's people
that use the distinction little less
versus big a stoic yeah you're talking
about the actual stuff waspy use you
know the big s capitalized its proper
now whereas our our little s is you know
think of Spock from Star Trek yes you're
you're you know unemotional yeah this
purely logical yeah you know you know
little a stoic and say yo uh Oh what is
that a straw stoic yeah do you think
there's do you think you could say
something similar with Buddhism like
obviously it's not gonna be upper case
and lower case B Buddha yeah but that
there's a yes a trope yeah that's that's
a good way to put it I mean with this
with the stoicism thing what I don't
have happening was stoic philosophy
which had been studied for a long time
became connected with intellectual
culture and then people stripped away a
lot of the important elements of it and
focused primarily on the toughness the
unemotional 'ti and you know a few other
things and that became the lowercase s
stoicism that we're talking about here
by about you know the early 19th century
I would say and so then then people
start using it with a lowercase s in in
discussions just talking about like you
know not showing pain
as being stoic I don't know that we have
something exactly correlative to that
and in Buddhism
you know another your similarity let me
bounce this idea off of you so you could
say that why should a person do this
widening of the circles or contracting
of the circles or you know trying to you
know think about people that that one is
not directly connected with as being
part of one's circle and and there's
answers to it that are what we could
called a ontological that is based in
duty yeah you should just do that that's
the right thing to do right and you do
get that in Buddhism and you do get that
in stoicism but you also get what we can
call you die monistic that is oriented
towards our own well-being or happiness
an attitude about it as well if you're a
stoic why should you do this you know
why should you take on the work of
trying to see your neighbors who are
probably kind of a pain to you at times
as being part of your family who you
feel affection towards because it's a
good thing for you to do ultimately it
makes you a better person and not like a
better person in the sense that you can
like Lord and over them
passive-aggressively and say see how
nice I am to you but it makes you it
leads you towards what what eudaimonia
happiness or fulfillment or you know
good sorry yeah what what that actually
is which is being the kind of person who
actually can be benevolent to others and
Buddhism okay there's there's a very
different conception of the self namely
that ultimately there is no self at the
bottom so that's different from the
stoicism but it's still good for you to
engage in Metta meditation why well you
know tying in with Buddhist metaphysics
and reincarnation it helps you get rid
of some of your Karma for one thing but
I think there's also a similar thing it
helps you to feel better in your life it
helps you to flourish in some ways right
to be connected there's other yeah I
totally agree like there's actually lots
of research especially being doing
done now about like how you volunteering
or giving gifts on
make you feel and and one of those
things that it does is it makes you you
actually feel better from giving like
you you and it lasts longer than to like
buy yourself something so there's the
kind of this idea of like treat yourself
and let yourself yeah and I feel like
maybe that's maybe a little much you
know you definitely need to like make
sure that you are getting enough sleep
and like maintaining yourself but um
from a if you're just looking for having
a happy life buying yourself over buying
someone else something yeah you're
probably gonna have a more enjoyable
life doing the latter now do you think
the motivation of the gift buying and
gift giving to another makes a
difference in it
so like for example line early what's
that I said mine early oh really so so
if I get you a gift and I'm doing it
because I'm hoping to get a gift in
return from you like me oh that
reciprocal relation or if I'm buying you
a gift because I want to show off or we
can think of all sorts of not really on
point reasons for buying gifts as
opposed to just wanting something good
for you and saying oh wow this would be
really great for Dan he's been want he's
been talking about this book that he
hasn't been able to get for a long time
here's a copy I'm getting this for him
right what does the motivation make it I
guess I jumped the gun a little bit
because I was first thinking that you
were gonna say life doesn't matter that
and I'm gonna feel better about this or
if I'm just looking for my livers in
which like you know mightily but if you
if you're doing me what you would asked
to the I does that person is he's trying
to show up or something yeah yeah I
think you know the motivation like
really ski
use it as well as you know part of is
that you're trying to elicit some
enjoyment in the recipient and if the
recipient despises the thing your
enjoyment of it decreases and so if you
get something that someone really wants
but you say like well yeah and I you
know had to skin 12 monkeys to get it
and you all of a sudden you recoil
because do you think that yeah yeah I
was like why why hey hey to pull this
out of the hands of a homeless person
for whom it was the only possession yeah
that'd be pretty pretty awful wouldn't
it right and and so now now it feels
like you you've given them like this
false hope you know I can't even look at
the thing given them a poisoned gift
right yeah yeah I don't think that has
the same feel but I can't point to any
particular studies I have read well you
know we we did that entire show a long
time ago that people might want to tune
in to about giving for Riverwest radio
right and we explored some of those
issues in there particularly what
happens when you give somebody a gift
that they really don't want mm-hmm how
that's sometimes that's worse than
giving them nothing well let's should we
should we talk about utilitarianism sure
we can jump back to if we have more time
we can jump back to any of the stuff
that we didn't get to
so utilitarianism is a philosophy that
officially begins in the 18th century
with Jeremy Bentham but it the general
idea had been around for quite a long
time and you don't just find it in
Western philosophy as a matter of fact
in Chinese philosophy the moa school who
worked very influential for a while but
unfortunately died out they were
effectively utilitarians just you know
in a very different context and one of
the things that Bentham stressed was the
importance of been what he called
benevolence meaning this this
disposition to as he put it
to take pleasure in other people feeling
pleasure because everything for the
utilitarians at first was about pleasure
in pain they were their hedonist and so
if I give you that that gift and let's
not make it a book let's let's find
something a little bit more relatable
for four people what's what's what's
your favorite food
Oh or something that you would like to
get say in the mail you know on I really
very much enjoy dragons milk out of left
hand brewery in Michigan okay kind of
beer right yeah it's it's a dark creamy
delicious Porter okay I can relate to
that definitely because I like that sort
of stuff as well so I order it online
and it arrives at your door and nobody
steals the package and you know you get
it inside and it's got a little note I
suppose or something like that it says
enjoy all right
now if I you know if I feel neutral
about it that's not benevolence that's
you know maybe I did it for some other
reason but if I actually take delight in
your delight that's that's what Bentham
called benevolence so there's an
effective part to it it's not just the
doing it's it's the motivation the
opposite of that is malevolence where I
enjoy your pain or when you actually
enjoy something I feel bad about that
because I would prefer you to not feel
good about it and along with benevolence
would also be you know if you are
feeling trouble or pain or something
like that I don't I don't necessarily
feel the same thing it's not like
emotional contagion but I feel bad that
you feel bad
alright so Bentham thought that this is
a really important motive in human
behavior and he talked about the
difference between what he called
particular benevolence which is really
easy to feel towards those who we care
about you know friends family maybe our
neighbors and then you talked about
Universal or general benevolence and he
said that the problem with most people
is not that they're not benevolent at
all it's that they're only benevolent
with
with whom they've got some sort of
connection and they don't really care
about how other people are being
affected and so he wanted to try to
promote universal benevolence as how
human beings ought to view themselves
you know comport themselves the way they
ought to behave and there's a lot of
transformations that happen there's you
know some other important utilitarian
philosophers John Stuart Mill well worth
reading he refines it a bit this guy
Henry Sidgwick who nobody really reads
anymore except us moral philosophers but
it was really worth reading he does it
as well and then we get down to somebody
who's who's kind of considered to be one
of the bad boys of contemporary
philosophy by many people Peter Singer
and I guess you know he's considered to
be that because he's a consistent
utilitarian and he really does think
that we what the utilitarians think that
we ought to take everybody's outcomes
into consideration good or bad when
we're making decisions now he has a book
called the expanded circle so or the not
the expanded expanding circle yes
expanded would be a you know fait
accompli we finished it it's a project
for for the contemporary times this so
you know oh go ahead yeah so like part
of this is you he he is trying to make
an argument for why we ought to care
about all people on the world in this
utilitarian idea and so first he talks
about like you know caring for children
and like you see a child drowning in a
pond and say the pond is only 3 foot
deep and you have zero chance of having
anything harmful happened to you for
going in and saving this child but you
have like $300 shoes on or yeah well
pseudo that's right yeah you want
I need zero time to take these things
off in order to say them you are will
ruin these things so you are giving up
300 dollars of value in order to save
the child
and basically everyone responds to this
all with the well yeah of course I'll
like go and say the child it's it's so
easy it's it's really like a almost
ingrained reaction like you you see a
child you save it and so the question is
he then poses once people usually answer
in the affirmative is okay well then
will you send a check right now for 300
dollars to save a child on the other
side of the world and all of a sudden
they get in this moral quandary and it's
like well if he only takes 300 dollars
to save a child then why am I not doing
that right now
yeah and you can make an a stronger
argument you can say it doesn't even
take three three hundred dollars it
could just be thirty dollars three
dollars are you willing to do that and
and a lot of people are like oh yeah I
don't know you know me they ask me next
week you know and then they they never
get around to it right so all right so
how does this tie in with expanding
circles then what is so general idea
there so the general principle here is
like we are predisposed to caring for
those that are closest to us either like
relationally or just even physically and
you know you have lots of experiences of
people you know dropping a hat to go
into dangerous situations to save two
strangers because they're in need at
that moment on and and so that you know
over the course of human history people
have expanded the circles of beings
whose interests they're willing to value
similar to their owns this is our talked
about over in groups that we talked
about earlier either Packers and
motorcyclists or yeah Christians or
whatever you want to put into there on
and then you know altruism he then
argues that altruism while directed at
one small circle a family tribe or even
nation is not moral but it only becomes
but it does become moral when it is
applied to wider circles because you are
doing a process of generalizing our
universalizing this altruistic
tendencies so there's no longer a divide
between oh I should do good for some
people but not for others if if the rule
is that you should care for people then
you should care for all people and not
just some people and yeah please we
should specify to that when when we say
that it it's not moral that doesn't mean
that it's immoral
right so caring for my my neighbor who I
formed this you know connection with and
they live right down the hall and maybe
walking their dog when they can't walk
their dog it doesn't become a bad act
because of that it just doesn't have the
same moral content that doing something
for other people who I'm not as close to
it have right right on there's a Oh what
is it super o supererogatory oh yes
there we go that's the word a
supererogatory so the thing that is good
to do but not bad not to do yeah and
often times so that we're getting into a
little bit of technical stuff here but
we sometimes talk about strict and non
strict duties and the non strict get
called supererogatory meaning that they
go beyond what you can ask for the
rotation is asking and super is above so
you know if I'm saving the child all I
got to do is save the kid right and then
maybe give them mouth-to-mouth if that's
necessary or CPR if I'm qualified to do
that I don't have to necessarily like
buy them a new set of clothes because
their clothes are wet that would be
super maggot ory yeah be nice yeah we're
gonna take them for ice cream you know
that's not necessary
but it would be a nice thing to do we
should probably get to talking about our
well right before that I just want to
finish up that's thing because sure last
part of this book is is why you there's
usually this idea or this like he kind
of sets up as a bit of a dichotomy or
old dichotomy these trying to break of
the you know rational reasons for caring
versus emotional reasons for caring and
who says that these aren't actually on
in conflict for us it's our emotional
reasons which you know give us
idea that we should care for each other
and as our a reason that allows us to
rise above our base level of concern and
extend that emotional caring and
instinct of caring to a larger group of
people so so ideally we wouldn't have to
choose between emotion and reason those
would be integrated with each other in
in our response they would play off of
each other right correct yeah I think
that's a very attractive way to look at
it and going back to the thinking about
the Stoics I think that's that's
perfectly in line with their point of
view on that as well so he's kind of a
fusing is Contin hume here
yeah well he's overcoming him right
human reason can only be the slave of
the passions
yeah and Kant was a little bit actually
I won't say a little bit count was far
too realistic yeah the passions you know
have no effective role in morality for
Kant so yeah that's a really good way to
put it and that's consistent with the
other utilitarians as well so we're
getting a little bit short on time do we
want to skip over the the question and
spend a bit more time on the practice
this time or do you think um I think we
can spend just like a four minutes on
the question okay so you know one of the
things that comes up whenever people
talk about this these these circles
especially for us Americans is should we
shouldn't we care more about our country
you know after all America is supposed
to be this this wonderful beacon city on
a hill as as one of the Puritans put it
although of course that came with
responsibilities that many people
overlook in that sermon from John
Winthrop so should should we do we have
an obligation to care mostly about our
country's sort of like what Cicero was
saying or should we care about people
more
people both in the wider circle outside
of our country outside of our large
in-group and people within the the
country and there's a lot of ways we can
we can approach this I think what are
your thoughts Dan it's it's a really big
question and and there's you know the
distinction between like what is my
nation is my nation my like our cultural
ties is it like the political structure
is it you know a national identity or is
it something you know a little bit more
strong like nationalism and and where do
these things lead us down some negative
paths yeah and you know I think that one
one aspect of the way Americans look at
things what's often called
exceptionalism has not been very good
for us in in the long run there are some
some ways in which we can say there's
you know we've excelled and and I'm not
just thinking about like you know out
producing people or stuff like that I'm
thinking about some times and places
where we've done really good work and
but there is a tendency to say you know
USA over everything and then it's not
really much different than someone in
some other country saying my country is
the best my people right or wrong you
know get out of our way and we we don't
have much recourse when other people say
those sorts of things other than to say
well we're tougher and stronger and have
more money right now that won't last
forever though and and one of the things
and I was talking with you about this
earlier there's a song by the composer
Yann Sibelius which which has become the
Finnish national anthem and it's a
really wonderful song that that I like
quite a bit in part because I won't read
though the actual lyrics here but he
talks about how great his nation is how
wonderful it's guys are you know bluer
than the ocean and
you know it's it's just as good as it
can possibly get but then he says at
each time that he brings that up but
other people love their country just as
much as I do their countries are good as
well and I think that there can be a
recognition of the importance of the
homeland with the Latin the the Latin
they called the patria the the you know
mother country or [ __ ] fatherland or
whatever you want to call it that gives
it its its right value without
denigrating everybody else and maybe
that's where it goes wrong when it when
it's USA is the best because we beat the
Russians at hockey or you know although
you know the Miracle on Ice was was
pretty cool they I have to admit having
it but when it becomes about denigrating
others and asserting power over them and
exploiting them that's when it goes
wrong right and and maybe we can say
this not just about nationalism we could
say this about families what if I
prioritize my own family to the
detriment of the other families in my
neighborhood something is going wrong
there right right Philly brings up that
you know zero-sum versus positive some
games once again that we've spoken about
and just the idea that if if you're
thinking of national nations as a
zero-sum game then my gauge nations gain
can only come at your nation's detriment
and to think of it as a more positive
sum game that we can both have and build
better nations and we can it doesn't
mean that your nation has to it will
suffer in order for us to be good yeah
and you know maybe the jockeying for
position in that way it comes from an
emphasis on the wrong kinds of goods
that aren't you know totally without
value but but you know think about honor
for example or you know we can say call
social status now think about it between
countries if one country is is
is taking more than its fair share of
that then everybody else has to have
less and why would they be tempted to do
that because they're all about that
anything about the prick leanness of
certain countries that are quite
insecure about their their own value you
know and they have to jockey with other
countries and again we could say this
about neighborhoods we could say this
about cities you know we could say this
about families yeah New York and Boston
yeah that's well then we have our own
rivalry here right with hockey and
Chicago so I think we should move on to
practice here in order to get through it
enough any Chicago people cuz you know
oh yes they take Milwaukee side we can
build a better world together
so our practice on here is going to be
Metta meditation that we just poke on
just a little bit and it comes from on
the Buddhist tradition and so the the
practice as I smoked about earlier is
the idea of bringing to mind on someone
that you have zero CH of difficulty in
like feeling love for and like maybe
it's a parent or a spouse or a child I'm
someone that like you you think about
and it's like immediately it's just like
you know flowers and rainbows or
whatever you want to say you know every
there's always a little bit of tarnish
but you know it's it's easy to love them
regardless and on and to take this and
like try to cultivate that feeling -
like really elicit that in your mind's
eye on and and then you start to think
about you know other ones you know
people that are neutral to you and you
try to maintain the same level of you
know love this emotional feeling of love
and you try to you know just associate
it with these neutral ones and then you
do it for those people who are difficult
those people that you know their rulers
are annoying busy bodied arrogant
self-righteous vice full
neglectful war profiteers fence sitters
naysayers charlatans those who are
unkind accusers and rebuke errs wires
and those that are just unhappy and you
want to try to you know still elicit
this this feeling and you know depending
upon how you're feeling with you you
also want to think about you and this
point because sometimes it's hard to
feel love for ourselves and this is a
good practice to it will encourage
ourselves to have a little bit more yes
self-esteem to love each other to be you
know more accepting of ourselves in this
moment and then let me ask then how does
one hold on to that feeling
and you might say transfer it to these
people that you don't you don't normally
feel that feeling towards a lot of
people would say I can't change my
feelings but isn't is is it possible to
do that well it seems like from at least
my personal experience and from the
writings have read about this is that
you know emotions linger and if you can
listen in emotion of something that's
really loving then it's going to linger
and it you're not gonna immediately turn
to anger when you're talking to someone
who is really negative around you that
you will actually still have that a
positive experience and are you great
you still there I am okay you've moved
okay on and the last thing is to expand
this feeling - you know all beings you
know rational beings or humans forever
you're gonna cut the line for yeah so I
imagine this takes a lot of practice to
do well right yeah
I don't know I think it took three or
four times me doing this to like start
getting it to like feel like it's having
a little bit of effect you know it's
gonna take more to you know think of
that person that you've hated since you
were six yeah and you're like oh yeah
like you know that guy he's great you
know yeah you might not even say he's
great but like at least you're not
feeling that that immediate negative
reaction to even thinking about this
person so it's it's it's effective and
it's also cognitive but it wouldn't
result in you going out and like seeking
them out and and doing something to
improve their lives right or could it
encompass that or lead to that sort of
thing I think you could definitely lead
to it if you are removing your negative
affect towards someone to Elyse to a
neutral thing you know you're no longer
avoiding the person and even in the
first place you you know if you really
dislike someone then you're like oh that
person's here I'm getting the heck out
of here
yeah well that's that's you I'd have to
have watched the reaction of like going
up to them and and starting a conflict
demotic in that respect that is driven
by that that part of ourselves that
tends to seek out conflict that way now
you you mentioned you can apply this to
yourself as you're doing it so would you
you know a lot of us like ourselves too
much you might say but maybe there's
parts of ourselves that we we don't like
we recognize ourselves as being among
the difficult people not necessarily to
ourselves although we often do get it in
our own way but to other people so how
does Metta meditation apply that you you
then turn that that affection or love
towards the bad part of yourself that
you you recognize as problematic yeah so
like for example you see that you're
you're not good at something and maybe
you you hold that as a something that
you would
like to improve upon but like maybe
you're just you're just not a natural
basketball player but you know all your
friends love to play basketball and so
you go and play basketball with them but
you really stink at playing basketball
and so you're you feel bad that you
can't you know participate fully with
these people that you care about and and
it's kind of like this idea of forgiving
yourself and still feeling loved at
yourself even though that you've failed
at certain things you know that failures
and like the only thing that matters
about you you know that's that's
interesting I mean there's going back to
the Stoics and talking about connections
between these so the stoic concentric
circle things doesn't have that but
stoicism in other parts does have that
forgiveness of self and not not letting
yourself off the hook for the the
problematic aspects but also recognizing
that you can change them that maybe
they're not as bad as you you think the
only really bad thing is is being a
vicious person right mmhmm yeah yes the
Buddhists don't quite use the
terminology of virtuous and vicious
they're yeah in that exact sense but
yeah so you know and just to you know
back this up you know with you know
besides a couple thousand years of
Buddhist practice there's actually been
quite a number of studies and there one
of them is on a meta study of the
effects of loving-kindness meditation on
positive emotions a meta analytic review
by Professor Sheng from the Hong Kong
University and their findings from this
was a 2015 study and the findings were
that on from a medium-sized improvement
to daily positive emotion with
meditation on a loving-kindness aspect
of Metta and this is having a greater
effect than practices with focus on just
compassion and so the length of this
meditation did not affect the magnitude
of the positive impact so you don't have
to spend a whole lot of time
yeah yeah very interesting well any any
final thoughts before we got a couple of
books here really quick yeah so sister
Rose on duties which you can find easily
online is a great place to look you'd
want to look in book 1 Peter Singer we
mentioned already the expanding circle
really great book you can get here at
Cleese the translations of his stuff in
a book called here Cleese the stoic any
particularly good thing I'm Metta
meditation that you can pick out not
Afghan unfortunately okay that study
maybe and so will close out here with an
African proverb you want to go fast go
alone
[Music]
you